alors ça vous plaît bah je sais pas
c'est sa maman de commander 2 on n'est
pas très concernés c'est ce à quoi je
pense ça touche pas les gens vraiment
bien ça c'est moche et les gens si mon
avis c'est pas mal mais ces giboulées
faut viser large quoi on a eu une petite
faut que ça soit plus plus accessible
monde font que ce soit qui ait le tout
public quoique si vous voulez en même
temps même temps faut que ça reste de
qualité que ça c'est bien 6 2
merci merci beaucoup aux professeurs oui
en théorie je crois que c'est très clair
un j'entends ces observations je crois
qu'il ya très clairement de la part du
téléspectateur une demande très forte
dans le sens de la qualité
oui alors c'est prévu c'est la raison
pour laquelle nous allons diffuser
maintenant un documentaire culturel
assure la ville de venise et ses musées
seulement dans la mesure où le
téléspectateur n'a pas encore le niveau
intellectuel suffisant pour regarder ce
document dans son intégralité non
chiffrée nos enquêtes le montrent nous
allons diffuser 29 secondes cette
semaine et puis la semaine prochaine par
contre lorsque les téléspectateurs
seront d'habitués lorsque leur niveau
aura un petit peu augmenté
on pourra en diffuse et 43 secondes et
bien si de suite en augmentant de
semaine en semaine jusqu'à ce qu'ils
puissent le voir en entier
voilà
le grand canal font venise d'ouest en
est large et profonde cassure en forme
de s s comme sérénissime et tout au long
de ce grand canal côte à côte
s'appuyant les uns sur les autres les
palets s'alignent dans une harmonie
nullement altérée par la variété des
styles dans ça vous va là c'est pareil
c'est trop long trop courant des forces
populaires de qualité non a lancé m
samedi dernier vous avez employé le mot
prémices au masculin pluriel
alors qu'il est du féminin pluriel et si
vous ne me croyez pas regardez l'extrait
vous venez d'assister aux prémices de la
première guerre mondiale
passons maintenant à ceux de la deuxième
qui au temps pour moi
bah oui mais ça c'est très grave qui
rien parce que les jeux ne supporte pas
ce genre de fautes ils ont zappé
massivement on à perdre écouter regarder
la courbe là avant la faute fatidique
ici et ici paf prémices à l'essai
l'hémorragie ah oui les gens ne
supportent pas ce genre de fautes ils
ont écrit par milliers à la chaîne 1
pour dire qu'ils ne paieront plus la
redevance si c'est pour entendre des
analphabètes massacrer la langue
française
les gens nous demandaient vous soyez
immédiatement remplacé par julien lepers
oui mais thierry reconnaissait la potins
alors maintenant pour compenser il va
nous falloir diffusé quatre secondes de
documents tu râles s'urbaniser série la
dignité du service public est à ce prix
il s'agit de la dignité du service
logement la voyant pas revenir au
débouché du grand canal
la salle haute et opéra baroque ciselé
dans la pierre blanche dresse sur le
pourtour de sa coupole tout un peuple de
statut vibrante comme les choristes d'un
thé des hommes quand tous les cuivres de
l'orchestré qu'on a fait de jeu de la
qualité on pourrait maintenant penser un
petit peu l'art dit maintenant pourquoi
pas attirer les yeux ça va durer cinq
secondes
passera pas attention 1 2 3 c'est
scandaleux du service public en voyez
bien que nous
paradoxe encore de l'architecturé
vénitienne le palais ducal
la logique voudrait que tout l'édifice
safin
mais ça fait chier tout le monde venise
roland voyez pas que ça fait chier tout
le monde d'autres trucs de venise toutes
les semaines comme ça depuis le début
non ce que veulent les gens c'est du
sexe à télévision étatique
[Applaudissements]
allons-y
lucienne ça suffit rollin ça suffit avec
votre venue du sexe c'est ce qu'un
double doucet est ce que veulent les
gens encore de la faute le plus sexy
star
oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est pas raisonnable thierry nous
sommes là en train de nous entre
déchirer sexe contre culture il nous
faisons le jeu de nos adversaires
l'ennemi le véritable ennemi c'est ceux
qui ne regardent par dix matches mais
c'est comme en politique la gauche et la
droite s'entredéchirent
mais le vrai ennemi c'est les
abstentionnistes c'est notre ennemi sont
les gens qui nous regardent pas pour une
raison ou pour une autre ceux qui vont
au théâtre par exemple ca me voilà il
fait faire la guerre aux terres rares
étaient les questions q comment ça va
finir
top top 3 fautes thierry question
incongrue c'est de l'audimat facile
vous connaissez le tarif vous connaissez
la sanction 18 secondes de venise et
s'amuser omni nullement altérée par la
variété des styles
ainsi le gothique le plus médiéval
s'adosse avec bonheur au baroque le plus
délirant un gothique du sud avec des
ogives ensoleillé qui ont des cambrures
mauresque et voilà thirion vient
d'enregistrer une baisse catastrophique
je sais ce que vous allez me dire vous
allez me dire c'est de nice mais c'est
pas venu c'est vos questions incongrues
qui nous font plonger alors maintenant
débrouillez vous tirez s'est pas très
bien passé avec nous je vous en prie
s'est pas très bien passé avec nous
parce que sandrine a refusé de montrer
ses seins est ce que vous seriez prête à
montrer les vôtres montrez les nous je
vous en prie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
professionnel
[Applaudissements]
qu'est-ce qu'il ya un professeur mais
qu'est ce qui attend la marque topshop
faute mais c'est le problème condamné
avec sandrine pinto logique contre le
service public je regarde le barème une
paire de seins nus ça va vous coûter 13
secondes en ré seconde vague
[Applaudissements]
chemin de sa noble errance le grand
canal à l'endroit précis où il est le
plus étroit se laisse enjambé par le
rialto cette arche de marbre qui d'un
seul jet aggrave solidement les deux
partis flottantes voilà que ça vous sert
de leçon
[Applaudissements]
mauvais sort très bien thierry rien de
répréhensible dans ce sujet c'est
parfait j'ai vu comment elle s'est fait
fort est la pâte à modeler ah bah oui
mais là non croyants la faute ferry dans
le sujet ça allait bien mais l'a fourré
ah bah écoutez si évidemment il ya une
acception ensemble d'arbustes qui ne
coûte rien mais il ya une autre
acception four et c'était là votre verbe
transitif argotique baiser [ __ ]
[ __ ] et ben ça va vous coûter une
tranche de venise documentaires
culturels
je regarde le barème fourré forêts
pourraient pour et 26 secondes mais
aussi fleuri qu parfumer les palets
reprennent leurs fiers démarche
ivre de la beauté de leur propre image
qui se reflète depuis des siècles dans
le frémissement du canal un fripes et
voilà bien puni hockey à vous d'accord
[Applaudissements]
elle est pas mal gré les et là hop hop
hop hop hop hop hop faute faute faute
faute golez eh ben ça ça va vous coûter
un petit morceau nombre de données inter
culturel sur venise
on pensait
dix sept districts gol et gol et gol et
gol et quarante et une secondes devenues
[Applaudissements]
des remèdes aussi fleuri que parfumer
les palets reprennent leurs fiers
démarche
ivre de la beauté de leur propre image
qui se reflète depuis des siècles dans
le frémissement du canal un frémissement
que seul claude monet son cheval est
planté sur un quai moussu saura saisir à
la pointe de son pinceau magique mais je
vous dise moi je m'en branle devenu
l'espace
je m'envole branle 13 secondes je m'en
branle je m'en moque
[Musique]
je vous interromps il y a un petit
problème pour l'émission de ce soir je
vous dis tout de suite c'est de ma faute
la semaine dernière samedi dernier vous
avez dit je m'en branle
vous vous en souvenez grossièreté que
j'ai été obligé de sanctionner puisque
nous sommes sur le service public par un
extrait du documentaire culturel veut ni
cité des doges
mais et c'est là mon erreur je vous en
ai mis 13 secondes en me fiant aux
barèmes 92 j'avais dit les yeux
or j'ai reçu entre temps le barème 93
qui lui est de 15 secondes en branle
il ya par conséquent un reliquat de deux
secondes de venise qu'il faudra diffusé
à un moment ou un autre de l'émission
c'est comme vous voulez vais je préfère
apprendre la punition tout de suite à ce
moment-là professeurs comme ça on en
sera débarrassé de longvic je vais aller
planter sur 1 km au sud voilà pas de
problème
[Musique]
ça fait un moment que je vous voyais
venir avec vos gros sabots
la diffusion de cette séquence
pornographiques constitue une infraction
d'une extrême gravité
je suis obligé de sanctionner par 43
secondes de venise documentaires
culturels à venise après cet intermède
aussi fleuri que parfumer les palets
reprennent leurs fiers démarche
ivre de la beauté de leur propre image
qui se reflète depuis des siècles dans
le frémissement du canal un frémissement
que seul claude monet son cheval libre
l'audience d'appel terrible un nom en
effet ce n'est pas à proprement parler
terrible mais enfin ne vous plaignez pas
cette votre faudra vous qui avait
diffusé des cochonneries passé je n'ai
fait que mon devoir
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous il m'était
impossible